SPEAKER 1: The ability
for your business
to tackle the
unpredictable is critical,
whether tackling unexpected
shifts in supply chains
or surges in customer demand.
At the core, you
need a database that
can back your business,
power next gen applications,
and leaves all of the
management to somebody else
without breaking the bank.
So you don't have to worry
about quick shifts any longer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We demand a lot
of our databases,
and our databases
demand a lot of us.
Your database can be a
powerful engine or a management
headache.
Traditionally, databases tend
to be fragile, expensive,
and tough to maintain.
Without one that can
scale without limits,
provide data consistency, and
eliminate management overhead,
you're faced with an inability
to scale with new business
needs, data inconsistencies that
can risk losing your customers'
trust, and cost inefficiencies,
since IT teams are tied up
maintaining those systems
instead of innovating.
Your developers
wind up implementing
their own complicated
database sharding--
or partitioning--
strategy, which
leads to overprovisioning
of resources and ballooning
costs, not to mention the
cost of managing backups,
scheduling maintenance
windows, meeting
performance requirements, and
securing the entire thing.
You end up having to pick
between scale, consistency,
or management-free.
You can't have it all--
until we created
Google Cloud Spanner,
a fully-managed relational
database service
that scales horizontally,
is strongly consistent,
and speaks SQL.
Spanner offers an
industry-leading 99.999%
availability with
automatic software updates
and instant optimizations.
You get zero
downtime-- yes, zero--
and no maintenance windows.
It's used to power
workloads large and small,
from applications for
just a few to massive apps
with global users.
Spanner is simple
to use and manage,
so you can build
applications that
transform your
business while lowering
your Total Cost of Ownership--
TCO.
Let me show you how.
First off, Spanner offers scale.
For relational databases,
significant effort
is required to grow a
cluster horizontally
to support additional capacity,
and setting up data replication
in different parts of the
world has never been easy.
You're left with an extremely
complex architecture requiring
a specialized team to maintain.
With Spanner, you don't need
to shard or replicate data
nor build intricate frameworks
to scale up quickly.
It vastly simplifies your
architecture and operations
because it automatically
distributes data
and automatically handles
replicas, sharding,
and transaction processing
across regions and continents
so you can quickly scale
to meet any usage pattern,
deliver data closest
to your end users
with the lowest
possible latency,
and ensure success
of your products.
With a single click
or API call, you
can start with small workloads
and scale with no limits.
Choosing Spanner
means you won't need
to rewrite your applications
or migrate databases,
even as future
data volume grows.
This brings me to
my next point--
consistency.
Traditional
databases force users
to choose between
performance and consistency.
With eventual consistency,
you risk serving stale data
to customers, which
might not be acceptable
in time-sensitive situations
like retail, finance,
and gaming.
For example, showing
an item in stock
online when in reality,
it may be zero.
This can lead to a bad customer
experience and loss of trust.
Spanner uses True Time, which
leverages a fully redundant
system of atomic clocks.
That means Spanner
applies a timestamp
based on a globally
agreed-upon clock
to every transaction on commit.
Transactions in
different regions
are executed sequentially--
no ifs, ands, or buts
on the commit timestamp.
And finally, high availability--
Spanner offers up to an
industry-leading 99.999%
availability, so you're
protected from failures.
How?
Spanner provide
high availability
via a synchronous
replication between replicas
in independent zones.
It uses a Paxos base replication
scheme in which writes
are committed only when a
majority quorum is achieved.
You can choose between regional
and multi-regional replicas
that span continents
across the globe.
Unlike typical
database services,
Spanner does not need
any maintenance windows
or downtime.
Spanner are also offers
online schema changes,
meaning easy schema
updates, no downtime,
no disruption for your users.
Spanner is
enterprise-proven, secure,
and battle-tested at Google.
With features like manage
backup and restore and open
source emulator for local
testing, a variety of client
libraries and
performance tuning tools,
you can achieve business
continuity, lower development
costs, and empower
your developers
to get started right away.
Meanwhile, data-layer
encryption, IAM integration
for access and controls, and
comprehensive audit logging
give you enterprise-grade
security.
Spanner's been used in
industries like gaming
for user profiles and
real-time play data,
fintech for account
data and ledgers,
healthcare for medical
records and patient data,
retail for supply chain
and inventory management,
tech for real-time decision
making and performance data,
and media for digital rights
management and catalog
metadata.
Spanner is the enterprise
database giving you
the best of relational
and nonrelational features
with transactional consistency,
SQL support, automatic sharding
and replication, and
nearly unlimited scale.
Cost-effectively streamline
your IT operations,
give your end users the
experience they demand,
give yourself peace of mind
through its reliability,
and build transformative
applications
at the speed of your business.
Try it out for yourself by going
to cloud.google.com/spanner.
And stay tuned to hear
more about Spanner.
[MUSIC PLAYING]